예 안녕하세요 안녕하세요 어떻게 될까
고찰 생각하고 있습니다 남기에 걸렸지만 내 감기 거렸어요 내 관계의
휠체어 조심해야 최신 팩 감사를 자세 안건을 4
에 뭐 음 권에서 얘기 않고요
오늘의 및 e22 잃게 대해서 어떻게 얘기를 고민을 튀어 와서 또 싸우고
오피스에서 해서 원이 봐줘야 스파는
물론 하나의 이제 언어의 팍 추 인데요
곰이 딩 에 대해서 어떻게 생각하세요 4
제가 지금 그 강 가에서 하고
공부하고 있어요 내 한국사람을
뭐 만 계획에 없어 혼자 봤네요
거의 없소 4 해외 에 그러나 그 2기 듣기
예 그 아주 그 반응 것은 수입 l 인터넷 뜻으로 가 요런 해 줘 2
재미있는 내용이 에 잡아서 그 즐겁게 에 이고요
한국의 사구는 한국 사람은
에 영어로 그 얘기하는 아갈 기회에 아주 뭐 우선 그러나
언제 라 2 이거 수 있어요 4
j 그 이거에 그래서 재미있는 에 내용이 즐겁게 에 있는 그 시 꽝
없다면 그 테스트만
에 위해서 아이나 그 일하기 위해서 만 그 이는 그 눈 0 2
예 이렇게 에 바 전 할 수 없어
그렇기 때문에 제가 그 즐겁기 이제 제니 라는 것은 그 찾아옵니다
자주자주 그 잃어야 자 먼저 흥미가 생기고 재미있게 느껴지는 걸 먼저
읽고 왜 그래야 모 모 회사에서 비즈니스 관련해서 나 테스트 보토 풀 털
관련해서 몇 잉 을 할때도 독해를 좀 더 쉽게 훨씬 시킬 10 러쉬
이렇게 단 반 오만이 배우 르 배우 배우며 예 쉽게 이는 그 능력이 에
음 다 3 4 가면 언제나
으 na 향이나 er 빚을 내어 마이스 run 내용이나 쉽게 예술
됩니다 어휘력을 많이 작게 되면 어떤 트릴 라도 다 쉽게 읽을수
얘기한 그 능력이 애도 또 그 에 이거 통해서 어 1 2를 통해서 그 향
알제 그렇게 훼손 양상
이해가 되면 제가 누구하고 얘기 에 하얀 0
4 그러나 음 미 길 통해서 제가 조금씩 조금씩 돼야지 짊어 수정 4
으 놀라고 몰라 가볼 러버 에 의해서도 훨씬 뭐니 때 조금 쑤셔 가지고
깜짝 놀랐어요
4 그렇기 때문에 제가 또 한국 사람 내의
그 한국의 싸고 있는 사람이
에 무엇보다도 많이 많이 읽어야 합니다
이외 외국사람 자자 아 찾고
에 선생님 에 그 빌 없어요 1 따고 굳이 외국인과 많이 만나야만 회원을
잘할 수 있게 되는게 아니라 한국에서 영어를 많이 읽고 들어도 자연스럽게
회화를 회화 실력도 쌓을 수 있다
즉 쎄씨 않고 공부하시는 과정이 딱 그렇잖아요 많이 있고 만 찍고 내국인
한국도 아니고 캐나다에서 어느 한국 사람이랑 말도 않아 잘 저의 외는
사실 저랑 주살 얘기를 아래 때문에
그럼에도 불구하고 한 2주전에 저희 비디오 촬영 했어요 예 훨씬 많이 악
나옵니다
그래서 측면 허비 먼로 나 에 제 갱이 있어요 괴체가 저의 그 금 그거요
shae 1
절대로 비어있는 에 저감 찰 때는 이 경우 거야
험이 흥미를 횽이 없다면
전혀 뭐 이만 없어요 예 네 연락 4팩 반말 되요
8 이렇게 내가 3 나 라 4 라 합니다